[Laughter]
thank you
hey everybody what's going on has
everyone gained 10 to 20 pounds because
of Thanksgiving yesterday we've been
keeping it under control actually yeah I
had one plate yeah okay and admittedly I
did have a couple so today today I had
one yeah yesterday I also had one yeah I
had one plate yesterday now I did have
like some pie later
yeah and our plates weren't that piled
that but that's all I had and then today
I just have one plate and that's all I
mean there was a lot on it but it's not
like I had a big plate and then had
seconds and then went back later yeah it
wasn't a normal I wanted to yeah but I
was like yeah my stomach's not gonna it
wasn't a normal [ __ ]
Buffet because I didn't want to just
like go in a coma afterwards you know
what I mean because and well it's not
just that it doesn't just make me tired
it just like gives me a stomach ache it
makes me feel kind of like nauseated
we've kind of been on calorie
restriction kind of diets in a way and
our stomach's kind of gotten a little
bit smaller than they were we used to be
able to eat all that but if I can I ate
that plate was enough that one pretty
much they put me to sleep yeah yeah well
and then the day before like I said
because
um you know I think like a lot of people
uh you know the day before Thanksgiving
if you're cooking at your house like
usually it's like [ __ ] it let's just
order food out like get a pizza or
something because yeah you can't cook
anything in your kitchen right so we
actually went got Chinese food and I
used to be able to eat like you know the
the little meal they give you like for
the Chinese food but I couldn't even eat
that yeah I ate like half of it a little
bit and then I was just kind of like
yeah I'll eat the rest of it later yeah
we were like oh [ __ ] next time we'll
just split one yeah we should probably
just split it next time and I mean 45
for two people that's not bad and I mean
if you wanted like something a little
extra you could even get little sides
like a little soup or some [ __ ] like
that or like an extra egg roll or
something that would be plenty I feel
like because I mean the the plate is
kind it looks small but when you open it
man they pack it full yeah and it's just
kind of like it's a lot and it's a lot
of rice and it's a lot of meat yeah and
you know so yeah they're generous they
are yeah General sews chickens almost
all chicken yeah and I got sesame
chicken sesame chicken and the orange
chicken is just like the general yeah
chicken's good too yeah we ought to get
that because we can we both like that I
didn't have the sesame chicken it's
probably similar to General so as it
looks like it's not hot though because I
can't like I said I can't eat stuff I
can't do high anymore
I'll just sprinkled down it just tears
my God damn General sauce isn't hot
either it says on the menu it is you
didn't come with any red chili on it oh
I don't know like I kind of like that
but it's not my favorite I mean normally
I would get I usually like kind of like
the weird [ __ ] like I don't like egg foo
young
like shrimp and vegetables yeah I like
those too all that kind of stuff yeah
egg foo Young's good I love it Chinese
omelette it's so good like that sauce on
it's good remember that baby I remember
I made that yeah that's right I made
that before and remember that place that
used to be by our old house what was it
called Lee's Palace yeah they had really
good egg food yeah too like I got it
there a bunch yeah egg food the gravy
was just like um
pork pork bouillon
nothing more than just uh corn starch
base it was just cornstarch and water
beef bouillon and uh that was it if I
remember correctly and I think I think
it had either Five Spice in it or white
I think I might have had
white pepper yeah probably white pepper
I think and easy to make everything on
everything in the Chinese fast food is
easy it's all easy
you think it's exotic it's not you laugh
when you see what they're making that
out of like sweet and sour that's
nothing but just uh
uh you take soy sauce and uh
garlic and ginger and you cook that a
little bit and then you put um
ketchup in it
and then
pineapple juice and a little bit of the
maraschino cherry juice and a little bit
of cornstarch slurry and it turns into
that sauce that's all it is and then you
then you add your
vegetables and you know which is like
green peppers and then maraschino
cherries and a little bit of
pineapple and you pour that over
basically fried chicken or fried pork
that's all it is or fried shrimp or
fried shrimp yeah although I have to say
that the one ones that the sweet and
sour that you usually get at Chinese
restaurants like take out I mean I don't
even think it doesn't have I always
thought that was just like [ __ ] corn
syrup with red food coloring like like
when you get sweet and sour chicken at
like a Chinese takeout and it's just
like that thin red it's It's just
sometimes they don't put the um
uh soy in it and and the garlic and the
ginger that's what I'm saying so I
thought it was ketchup right vinegar I
forgot to add vinegar ketchup vinegar
and uh
juice pineapple juice with thickening
agent that's it
yeah it's made out of nothing
that's why they can that's why they can
charge what they charge and give Those
portions that stuff doesn't cost
anything you buy it in bulk not in this
country well and like I said it's kind
of like the Chinese takeout by Art just
up the street from our house it's like a
good deal because you get a lot of food
for 10.50 yeah and it's really enough
for two people or if you're just one
person it's enough for two meals like I
think that's enough for lunch and dinner
the um
a lot of the stuff that makes Chinese
fast food taste so different it's not
the ingredients it's the fact that it's
cooked in a wok
and Woks you know are very high
temperature
frying you know in a pan and they use
Wok tools which are like little screens
and
[ __ ] like
yeah like a little net metal net I
forgot what you call it like a not even
a slotted spoon like a sieve like a
sieve you're using that they're using a
big old spoon looking thing to stir like
a huge wide spatula
and uh you just take to make that egg
foo young it was just uh beaten eggs I
think a little bit of water I think it's
watered down a little bit and it might
be some seasoning in it I think there's
green onions in there might be green
onions and there's some kind of little
vegetable mix that they're gonna put in
there and they're gonna um throw that
into a Super Hot Wok and as it
solidifies they throw a bunch of bean
sprouts on top of it and flip it over
and it just
as soon as it starts floating and it's
brown and you decides they pull it out
and throw it in any any ingredients that
they're going to put in there like the
shrimp and the chicken it's already
pre-cooked they just throw it in there
make it an omelette that's all I'm
putting gravy on it put it next to Rice
nothing wrong with that I mean Chinese
omelette I mean to be honest like I love
eggs I could eat eggs well actually when
I lived by myself and didn't have much
money like eggs were cheap you know what
I mean and so nutritious yeah and I
would just kind of like [ __ ] I would I'd
go like all week and I would just kind
of have I all I'd have was like a you
know a couple dozen eggs and like a
thing of bread I would just come home
from work in the middle of the night in
front of a couple eggs and like put up
with toast and that'd be dinner that's
why you ate 125 pounds then well yeah
because that's all I was eating yeah
pretty much I mean I didn't eat though
well you're about 125 I think weren't
you I went down to 118 118. but like I
said it was too light she was she got
too skinny for a bit yeah I always
thought you looked better around 1 30.
yeah like my goal my my ideal weight I
feel like is 135 yeah like that's when I
felt like I looked the most put some
shape normal yeah because I felt like I
liked being like really really skinny
but then I thought I looked strange you
do want to know what she looked like at
1 30 just look up Angela White she
looked like Angela White he's always
prepared yeah comparing me to yeah
preparing me comparing yeah I'm not
drunk I promise yeah I just can't talk
question Angela White and Sophie D
that's what that's what she looked like
Zach says aren't eggs bad for
cholesterol
um no not as much as you might think I
mean the thing about it here's what
happened like I had really really high
cholesterol back in the day like I was
you know a lot overweight like I was
probably like 200 and how much did I
weigh at my
I was like 2 20 2 30 something like that
like at my highest weight
and my cholesterol was like off the
chain which actually like runs in my
family like high cholesterol my mom has
it my grandma has everybody like on that
side
so they were basically like well you
need to get your cholesterol down or
else and they were gonna put me on um
what's that [ __ ] uh Lipitor oh [ __ ]
assistant and yeah and my mom had been
on it and my sister had been on it and
they're like don't go on that [ __ ] like
it just makes you feel like dying and I
was just kind of like yeah I'd rather
well I don't like to take things anyway
like I'm just that's just the way I am
and I don't usually have to and I just
got used to not doing that so um so I'm
like yeah I think I'd rather not even
though my doctor was like I really think
you should but I was like no I'm not
going to I said I'll try to get it down
naturally and what I did was now I did
cut out
um a lot of meat like I still ate meat
but not as much and usually I'd eat like
chicken turkey fish stuff like that I
didn't eat as much beef I cut that way
down I did cut down on eggs I mostly cut
down on Dairy and another thing that
helped a lot was eating oatmeal like
every day like in the morning and eating
oatmeal and grapefruit juice I did that
for for five months and my cholesterol
went way down like just from diet like I
wasn't doing anything else different
like I didn't take the and that it
doesn't work for everybody because some
people it's just you know it's because I
know that some people have tried to do a
diet it doesn't work it just depends on
the person but it worked on me
if you um go on YouTube just look just
Google or just just search for
the Rocks trainer and his name is like
doctor
tamazi so I think it was almost like my
name
and um I think he's an american guy
though
and he's a doctor
he's jacked though he looks good he he's
a sports medicine guy
and uh he'll tell you that um
the problem is not food the problem is
Americans Americans are sedentary they
just sit all day mostly they're not
doing what you were involved to do which
is work hard all day trying to find food
and kill [ __ ] or [ __ ] working all day
at a farm trying to plant food and
so no you can eat eggs you can you you
can eat dozens of eggs if you are active
your your cholesterol is no problem well
and the thing about it too I kind of
feel like another thing that's a problem
with Americans particularly is that I
don't think it's so much the food it's
the portion size because if you go to
like you know when I was in Europe and
stuff like that they eat like a question
of like fattier food than we eat but
they don't eat as much of it and they
walk around more and they're doing more
of that kind of stuff you know what I
mean whereas Americans will eat a lot
more at one meal sit there and they
don't like move around as much Americans
are fat asses compared to the restaurant
look at chat look at the Chinese or the
Koreans you know they're very slender
now
um or at least they were when I lived
there I lived in Korea and I heard that
they're starting to get kind of Western
diets and Western lifestyles of sitting
around on damn devices all day which
that's not the way they were when I was
there and they're getting a little
they're getting fat people but fat
people are kind of unusual and you know
that's something you only see in Rich
civilizations that have a lot of
Technology
because most people have to go out there
and [ __ ] work all day they can't
afford this [ __ ] cheap food and their
civilizations don't have cheap food or
it's cheap food but they're not making
enough to buy even cheap food you know
a lot of places are kind of like places
like Pakistan you know they don't have
no money for even cheap food a lot of
them so they they're working and they're
they're slander well they could eat
anything you know because they're
they're very active
um
but
he goes that that trainer he'll tell you
that even portion size is not a problem
if you're
if you're doing weight training and
doing hard work and you're working every
day he says weight training you know
even more if you want to lose weight
weight training is even better than any
aerobics because you're only burning
calories when you're doing the aerobic
exercise
when you're weight training you're
burning the calories for [ __ ] 24
hours a day because you're trying to
recover from all that tearing that you
did in muscle tissue
so I go out there and work for [ __ ]
a half not even a half hour most of it's
recovering in between [ __ ] I did I'll be
in My Little Gym here for a half hour an
hour and if you were actually to
condense it down to how long I was
actually lifting 10 minutes maybe total
and then I'll spend two days try to heal
up from that now I'm burning fat the
whole time try to rebuild
you start throwing in [ __ ] anabolic
agents it's even [ __ ] more intense
it'll just take fat right off you some
of them depending on what it is that
you're on
but uh you know that that's something
when you're older when you're young if
you're under the age of 30 you should be
able to do that just with weight
training you should really shouldn't
need any assistance you know but uh
that's all it is aerobics is good as
some things you know I mean it'll it
does burn calories it does take a little
bit of fat off it's just not as
effective as other stuff that's out
there
and you don't want to dye it
diets sometimes would just slow the
metabolism down which would make you
hold all the fat now you can go into
starvation mode but you'll lose fat
you'll lose muscle first and then you'll
lose fat
um that's uh what he was recommending is
actually eat eat eat normally and just
do a little bit of weight training
you'll lose a bunch of fat
I noticed that one of the easiest times
that I lost weight was when I was in the
UK even though I was eating way fattier
food than I would normally eat because I
was eating like you know Cornish pasties
and fish and chips and stuff like that
but I walked everywhere and how old were
you during those times no 30s 30s yeah
but that well because you had like I
said I didn't have a car when I was over
there and like I said it's much more of
a walking culture even if you have a car
you drive to the city center and then
you walk around all day like doing your
shopping and [ __ ] like that and then go
back to your car at the end of the day
soon in Boston that's what I mean so
it's kind of like that's why you see you
know that's why you don't see I mean
well the thing about it like over there
now now they have the same like fast
food and [ __ ] like that is us and their
portion sizes are still not well they're
still not as big as ours I did see a
video the other day that was comparing
portion sizes in like McDonald's to
America to Europe and their portion
sizes are still significantly smaller
than ours yeah
um you know so we probably eat like way
more than we should be eating those
German girls that were I was hanging out
with when I was up in Boston were
tripping out over [ __ ] portion size
you went to Chili's and they were just
they they couldn't believe yeah every
European that I've known like when they
came and ate at a restaurant they were
just like what the [ __ ] like this is
like three people's worth of food which
technically it is and really none of us
could eat it I think it was Chili's
it was the one that had she got that
damn blooming onion what was that where
it's blooming onion was oh that's one of
the steakhouses in that um Outback it
might have been the Outback or is it but
I don't know I don't know if it was the
blooming onion or a copy of a blue man
onion it was like that yeah because a
lot of a lot of them had now because
yeah I think it might have been Chili's
or something I don't think it was at
Outback
and uh
we went out to a couple of them over a
period of days and they realized that
they were all about that size and I was
just like yeah they're all competing
with one another whoever gets the most
whoever hands out the most food for the
most money is going to get all the yeah
the customers well [ __ ] man they don't
pay anything for that food
you know that those corporations don't
you know get great deals on that [ __ ]
you know like there's no difference they
could give you three times the amount
and it really wouldn't cost them much
more
I was thinking the other day because I
saw a commercial for you know how Olive
Garden has that never ending possible
something yeah oh man I'll get you fat
and it's just kind of like well honestly
I'm sitting there thinking well they
also give you like the unlimited salad
and breadsticks too so I'm just sitting
there going how much I would be
interested to see like after you do
breadsticks and salad even if you don't
get extra breadsticks and salad if you
just eat like what they bring you you
can't eat much of that and then it's
like how much pasta can one person
actually eat not much you know what I
mean it's like look I love pasta I'm not
saying that but it's like once I ate
like one bowl like especially if I had
to have salad before I probably want to
throw up it's like it's too much you
can't eat that much of it it's real
filling I'm like I'd be interested to
know if like people could actually go
back and like get even more pasta like
never any but does anybody take
advantage of that is yeah I think it's
all that's what I'm saying real
fattening
I love pasta it's delicious but I can't
eat that much of it you see like back in
Italy when they with you know
a peasant wouldn't eat very much of that
you know what I'm in a small bowl and
that's what they that was a whole meal
you know that would keep them going all
day they'd probably drink a beer and
wine on top of that too
and maybe like a piece of fish wrapped
up piece of lettuce maybe some olive oil
on it some herbs
it wasn't these [ __ ] Mega huge
[ __ ] yeah big salad bowl
filled with like a whole [ __ ]
two inch [ __ ] it looks good I'm not
saying that like I said I love pasta but
3 000 calories of [ __ ] pasta I think
it's more than that absolutely
five thousand probably I mean it would
be fine if that's all you ate for like a
couple of days yeah no there's no
nutrition
no I'm just saying calorie-wise you know
what I mean yeah there's there's no
nutrition in it really well if you got
one that had like other stuff in it like
cheese and veggies and you know some
meat and stuff it's equivalent of just
it's just bread but it's just like
eating bread you take a whole loaf of
bread and smash it down into a bunch of
little things and that's that's
basically bread like I said I'm just I I
don't think I could ever go on that like
you know because some people are just
like all no carbs and everything like
that I know carbs will like put fat on
you faster than anything but I'm never
gonna like give carbs up I I don't mind
like not eating them as much but you
can't because everything there's carbs
and everything yeah
that's what I'm saying
when it comes to fast food
you can go to McDonald's or you can go
to Burger King and as long as you just
get a [ __ ] hamburger and and don't
get the french fries and don't get the
the soft drink I don't even trust diet
soft drinks and just eat that hamburger
that's actually not all that it's not
that bad not that bad as long as you
don't get one that has like 40 bajillion
things and sauces and all that kind of
crap it's got everything you need it's
got a little bit of carbs it's got
protein on it's got vegetables it's
flavor well that's I always kind of like
the more Club type sandwiches like
something about like the chicken
sandwiches like tomatoes and lettuce and
[ __ ] like that it's like they now I will
say Burger King in particular is bad for
this they put too much mayonnaise on
stuff and I love mayonnaise okay I'm not
saying that but they're a little
heavy-handed with the mayonnaise at
least when I go there and sometimes like
McDonald's as much as I love the fish
sandwich and as much as I love tartar
sauce I feel like they're a little
heavy-handed with the tartar sauce on
the fish sandwich I think that's why the
fish sandwich that's like the double
fish it has that's why I think it's
better because there's a better tartar
sauce to fish ratio yeah the dough the
double fillet because the single one I
always feel like there's a little thing
of thing like I like them I get them
sometimes times but there's then it's
like a whole other layer of tartar sauce
and it's too much I have to scrape some
of it off the thing is that the double
filet of fish has got that breading on
it and that's that's a lot of calories
on it you're probably better off just
with the hamburger
Well yeah if you look at the calories
count
generally
um yeah if you get a if you get a burger
like without cheese yeah like even you
get a double burger because it's just
like bread vegetables and meat it's like
not the cheese that they're using is not
cheese the cheese they're using is uh
it's a cheese product yeah
American cheese or Velveeta it's whey
protein so it doesn't even it's it's
good for you so it's just it's probably
nutritionally better than the meat
which uh a lot of people have a hard
time grip come to grips with that but
American cheese is not cheese it's whey
protein yeah it's not cheese and that's
why they give it out you know from
welfare you know food assistance and
stuff they give out them big old blocks
of government cheese
because that's more like a meat that's a
protein
you you put a bunch of that
you know in Idiocracy they would just
put it in a bowl and eat it with their
fingers remember that movie Idiocracy
they're just eating it that would be
actually be that's like something a
bodybuilder would do because that's
that's pretty high protein
um and the calories are kind of low for
what it is
um so it's not going to add that much to
that burger
the the the worst thing on that
hamburger is the bread
because that's that's a lot of calories
a lot of carbohydrates in that
you know for its size
probably the most nutritious thing in
there would be that uh
a quarter pounder
the Double Quarter Pounder if you ate
just that that Double Quarter Pounder
that'd be pretty good it'd be pretty
yeah that's pretty good fairly bound I
mean for a fast food meal like it's you
know it's not ideal but if that's like
all you got then there's a lot of
protein there yeah the calories are not
that high and it's going to say 1100
1200 calories you're talking about the
french fries and the soda with that too
yeah the yeah the sandwich itself I
can't remember because I used to look up
the calorie things like just out of
curiosity I think just a regular Quarter
Pounder maybe three four hundred
calories something like that maybe it's
more I can't remember but it's not that
much I was surprised that yeah but when
they say I like that they have the
calories on there but usually the
calories for the whole meal they're
they're saying yeah you're gonna get
french fries on the side and you're
gonna get soda and that's where it's all
is and that's where most of the french
fries are the killer that's [ __ ] all
which is which is a shame because I
[ __ ] love you yeah and McDonald's got
good french fries
I mean and if we go to McDonald's which
we don't usually and especially not now
because there's one around here but I'm
gonna get some [ __ ] french fries God
damn it if you're not a teenager or
you're or you're just not checked on
[ __ ] anabolics that's gonna go
straight to your waist your metabolism
got to be [ __ ] running
to uh to take potatoes and turn that
into something like flesh it's gonna
want to become fat
and then the the
soda and I think even zero calorie I
don't believe it's zero calorie uh uh
[ __ ] diet soda
I read a thing saying like yeah your
body responds to that the same as it
would be if it was sugar anyway well
Zach is saying aren't diet soda is
actually worse for you than right I
think they might be I'm you know I'm not
sure if they're worse necessarily but
it's just kind of like I don't know it
to me it seems like not worth it like I
said I'm not a big soda fan I love them
um yeah Tom's really into them and like
every now and then he'll get a wild hair
across his ass and he'll go get like
some two liters or like stock up on
those yeah like it will go to Win Dixie
or and get the check Cola or the Publix
brand or whatever I'm not gonna spend
more than a dollar for two but I don't
drink any of them yeah I just I don't
and every now and then I like them but
honestly if I'm drinking out of the can
like I'll have a sip or two and I'm like
yeah I'm done but it's it's sugar well
it's sugar yeah that's and I suspect I
get the diet once
because they're not quite as sweet as
the as because I don't like I don't like
um that uh corn syrup
I like Mexicans drinks because it's cane
cane sugar it's a lot a lot of people
like those better um it does have a
better flavor it's a lot more mellow and
it's mellower it doesn't have that weird
sharp yeah
uh it's got more of a base flavor to it
um more it's not a sweet it's more
um kind of rich in a way it's more
Broadband Broadband the flavor is more
Broadband yeah it's a good way to put it
um and I I think sugarcane is a lot
better for you it's a lot easier to
digest you don't have so much of a of an
insulin response to that
corn syrup you have a massive insulin
response against that and it's that
insulin response that's telling your
body to store things as fat it's like
man we got this is a dangerous substance
we got to get this out of the system
store it let's hide it that's what it's
trying to do stick it over here stick it
over here in this person's eyes yeah
walking around real high insulin levels
is not good for Caucasians we really
didn't and send them with black people
we didn't really evolve to have high
insulin levels now uh Japanese and the
Chinese any of them civilizations that
were built on Rice they have a much
better insulin response and a tolerance
to insulin which allows them to digest
rice
um and this is that's a fact okay that's
why they can eat rice and not gain a lot
of weight weight on it and they have
very low diabetes all right
um black people are even more
susceptible to diabetes than white
people because even they are even less
tolerant to having a high insulin
response insulin in their system than
they're white people because it's just
kind of like a a fade
from black to white probably Hispanic
too and then into um
Asian
Asians are real insulin resistant
and they make a lot of insulin and it
doesn't [ __ ] them up so they can digest
rice anybody who couldn't do that died
thousands of years ago well that's what
I mean that's why it's been because
that's been part of their diet for like
such a long thousands and thousands of
years right well it's just kind of this
the same thing with like you know milk
how like a lot of people that you know
or lactose lactose intolerant because
Nordic people and white people can
[ __ ] just kid digest but a lot of the
rest of the world cannot uh because you
know normally you lose that ability once
you are weaned
uh Zach says you ever hear of Tropical
Smoothie Cafe yeah we have some down
here I'd never been to one but we have
them uh they're a healthy food type
restaurant but their stuff is actually
really delicious yeah I've never been
there
um one that I used to like that
it was sometimes in Mall food courts and
it was in our closest mall which is like
18 miles away but um was in the ultimate
mob was Nature's Table they mostly made
smoothies but they had like really good
sandwiches and soups and stuff too but
last time I was there they had closed
Unfortunately they talk about what's
healthy
well he was talking about Tropical
Smoothie Cafe I've never been to one and
Zach said um I also really love Panera
yeah I really like Panera too and
McAlister's Panera um I don't know if
they have it anymore but they used to
have this [ __ ] fantastic
uh mushroom like Panini that was like a
hole there was no meat on it it was just
like cheese and tomatoes and stuff like
that I think it was mozzarella and it
had like this big ass [ __ ] Mushroom
on it almost like it was like a pad of
meat oh my God that [ __ ] was delicious
yeah those those restaurants are all
good even that smoothie stuff's good
I'll [ __ ] love that but that's all
real sugary when you think about it
fruit surf [ __ ] you have
calorie problems with that and then
Panera everything's bread and cheese and
creams yeah it's good but man that's
it's fattening you know and and it is
but fatty the cleanest meal
you could get out of a restaurant is is
like a high quality Chinese buffet just
don't get the noodles don't get the rice
focus on the boiled shrimp and the meat
and you can you have the sauces and
everything
uh you can eat a lot of that because
just steal some protein I mean you you
went in there you know you punish them
for having a buffet you know don't try
to fill up all rice and bread and
[ __ ]
egg rolls and all that crap they want
you to buy that because
it'll fill you up but that's where all
the Fat's gonna come from
go straight to the meat
and it's okay if it's deep fried because
you're gonna it's gonna have some carbs
on it and then try to I always get some
of the crab rangoons I can't I can't
resist I always get at least one of
those yeah I can't resist them all right
usually I'll just get one yeah
all right and then they're going to get
the sauteed mushrooms remember they eat
a bunch of those yeah I like the pepper
steak because that's just that's just
meat peppers and onions that's really
good yeah and then the uh the one with
the uh still have uh chicken uh special
chicken breast with broccoli eat a lot
of that yeah all the uh I like all their
shrimp I like all their fish stuff yeah
like because it depends on the day that
you go but sometimes they have more fish
stuff than others yeah and if they got
the crab legs out for the extra four
bucks you four or five dollars to get
those two and then just eat crab
and uh but there's been times when we've
gone there we went to koi one and I
think I pretty much only ate shrimp
and I'm punished him I probably ate four
or five pounds of shrimp yeah I'll eat
shrimp in like some of the like the
little oysters they're not raw oysters
they're they're mussels actually their
muscles I mean yeah steamed mussels but
then like I'll have a little bit of that
I'll usually have some Wonton soup
because I do really like wonton soup but
then I'll just try I'll have like a
little bit I don't get any noodles I
don't get any rice I don't get anything
like that I'll get like some pepper
steak and I'll see what what fish dishes
they have because they'll usually have
like a bunch of different kind of fish
and yeah I like that if you pick through
it
and if oh if they had now if they have
peanut chicken yeah yeah that peanut
chicken's delicious
some of them some of those proteins
are very high in sugar and peanut and
all that so it's gonna be like candy but
it's okay because you're not eating
you're not eating all that rice and all
those noodles
yeah
so you're kind of making a trade there
and it bums me out because man I love lo
mein yeah I'm not a big I could take
them too I could take or leave rice I
don't really care about rice but I love
[ __ ] noodles and I love Romaine I
love noodles any kind of noodles like
[ __ ] glass noodles and I love that
David just showed up you going out
tonight David we're gonna go to
um yeah we're going to yeah
yeah we haven't been because we missed
the last one because I was broke
yeah so we didn't go to the last one
they did two last month you're talking
about deviled eggs deviled eggs could be
rough on you because there's a lot of
mayonnaise in there and there's a lot of
but I love them too yeah double dogs are
good yeah I didn't like them till I was
older which is really weird because I
always always don't like them I was
always a big fan of eggs growing up like
I loved fried eggs
um but for some reason boiled eggs like
weirded me out but then when I was older
and like I ate boiled eggs I'm like wait
oh these are good exactly what was I
thinking Zachary's in there complaining
that I'm getting him to think about
these skinny Asians I get Zach thinking
about skinny Asian guys and cute Jewish
boys he loves them good Jewish boys
we'll see there you go yeah now he's
gonna be like all he had a steak for
Leonard Nimoy when he was a kid see I
also have I also have the thing for
Leonard Nimoy then it was a sexy
[ __ ] man he was that's what I'm
saying no shame yeah it's like and
honestly like I said like our friend
Laura uh she just she's significantly
younger than us and she thinks she's in
her 30s I think or maybe early 40s and
she just discovered classic Star Trek
and so I was talking to her like at
mannequins like a couple like a month or
two ago and she had just discovered that
and she was like oh my God let her know
what like Spock is so [ __ ] hot and I
was like right and she was like I
thought I was the only person and I was
like girl you don't even know like the
whole [ __ ] history of the [ __ ] so she
was like she felt a lot better because I
think she felt like she was alone
because she was the only person
thought Spock was like super hot I'm
like oh my God no when that series was
running uh yeah the the studio was just
getting uh Love Letters From women about
there had to be more Spock and they
realized that they thought Kirk was
going to be the sex symbol turned out he
he got action yeah but he got action
girl women liked him but mostly guys
liked Kirk girls liked [ __ ] spot
because Spock was unattainable
he was he was a guy you couldn't get he
was like a forbidden fruit because you
could say but then they they threw in
but yeah I mean Shatner was a kind of a
hoe yeah yeah
was just typical male people with any
green skin [ __ ]
he was kind of typical male male Alpha
bravado it was the Alpha Sigma thing
going on between the two and then um
uh evidently uh uh [ __ ] bones McCoy
there was women that liked older women
liked McCoy I get that yeah I get that
you know women in their 40s and 50s like
McCoy well he has a very he has an
appealing personality because he's kind
of like crotchety but he's also like
really compassionate at the same time
which that that juxtaposition is very
appealing so so what they did is they
made what was called the uh the Triad
yeah and they started to write the
stories around
Kurt
spot and McCoy
and uh that's really when the series
started rolling and that they were
giving the audience what they wanted and
you had like I said the alpha the sigma
and then I wouldn't call him a beta he
was just a
The Compassion you had you had he wasn't
a baby he was just a normal yeah yeah he
well he was kind of alpha yelled at
people and [ __ ] right that's what I mean
I don't know well I think that whole
classification is dumb anyway because
well there is a there is an A A there is
a alpha and a beta and there there is
that kind of stuff it's just that it's
not necessarily permanent it's it can
change it depends on Dynamics but like I
said that's not science that's just uh
this name of Sociology it's just it's
manology you know um it's [ __ ] in
other words no
it was
um you had um you had
Kirk was about passion all right Spock
was about logic
and then you had uh McCoy was about
compassion you know yes he was like the
perfect yeah so that's like if you
combined all them together like perfect
man yeah well I mean from a honestly
like I think spot was the perfect man
but you know what I mean
uh Zach says I never had a thing for
Leonard Nimoy shush Leonard Cohen
meanwhile okay well okay I'll give you
that Leonard Cohen I I thought Leonard
Cohen was kind of hot too and I like
really like his music as well Graver
said wasn't Spock the original incel
no no because he wasn't a man well one
yeah he was an alien yeah and that was
just how their [ __ ] worked yeah and he
was he wasn't like involuntary was it
it's just like that's just the way their
culture was and it's like then she has
biology he only made it once every what
was it the uh seven years or eight years
he went through ponfar kind of like the
salmon kind of like salmon having to
spawn he wasn't human well he was half
human right he was happy but uh no Spock
had emotions
it's just that he had he had him wrapped
up you know what I mean see that control
I think that's what I always related to
because I kind of feel like people that
don't know that much about Star Trek or
don't know about Spock they're just like
oh he was emotionless no he wasn't
emotional he actually had stronger
emotions than humans yeah Vulcans over
time because they had these volcanic
emotions they were killing each other
they were killing each other so they
learned to suppress them in specific
ways so they still had them yeah they
just knew how to like [ __ ] do it and
see I was like I think that's what I
related to because you knew that all
there was like this seething cauldron of
emotion going on underneath there yeah
it wasn't like he was a sociopath or
anything like he didn't have any
emotions he was holding it back he was
just holding it back like he had learned
to do that and I think that was what
appealed to like to me like for his
character they adopted those
philosophies because they had such a
destructive and violent rape history
they were filled with uh uh
rage hatred violence and and and lust is
what they were
and they had a real violent history
and uh they changed over time they were
basically the same species as the
romulans the Vulcans and the Romans were
just basically say they were cousins
they were related
so if you ever see you know it was real
good
episode you know where
Spock and the rhyming that Captain and
[ __ ] got it going on
that might have been in um
that might have been in uh Star Trek
Continues
uh I think some of that was can some of
that we've got remember when they were
trying to steal the cloaking device yeah
yeah
if you guys want if you if you like the
old if you like the old series you gotta
see Star Trek Continues free on YouTube
it's fan made but it was written by a
lot of the same guys it has the kids of
the people who played the original
characters in there it's real Star Trek
and it's it's the final season of the of
the old series
and it ends where
it basically ends where Star Trek the
motion picture kind of begins you know
they're supposed to be like 10 years
there I think yeah they're like filling
in the gaps they're filling the gaps
yeah
American Military 100 general question
can you guys solve a debate I'm having
ooh let's uh okay what's the group Echo
and the Bunnymen considered goth or Post
Punk
um both they're generally considered a
Post Punk or goth band or uh or uh you
know like a New Wave band but they are
gotha Jason
um you know if you're a goth and you
like Echo the bunny one no one's gonna
say boo with you I mean honestly they
were one of the earliest bands I got
into and they were actually uh fun fact
they were the first band I saw live in
1987. a lot of a lot of recognized goth
bands borrowed a lot from Echo and the
Bunnymen in terms of sound they were
very doorsy echoing the bunny men with
the doors but the doors were kind of
gothy like yeah I could say they were
goth Kinda Yeah Proto very pretty sure I
would say what was more got than that
would have been the Velvet Underground
and they were Linked In with they knew
Jim Morrison and all those guys I think
they cross paths and I also love The
Velvet Underground yeah I wouldn't come
out and say they're a goth band but
they're definitely Proto Punk the
proto-goth yeah it was Proto it was it
was yeah it was good I mean if you
listen to this Eco yeah like I said if
you listen to Nico's album The Marble
index yeah that is very very like that's
very good that's very bad thing it was
just Gotham it's time
but to Echo and the bunny man kinda
Sisters of Mercy took some from them
fields of the Nephilim took some from
them and they just kind of had their own
uh uh the mission UK kind of took some
from they just the goth versions of it
just kind of made it a little darker and
a little a little heavier in some ways
depending on what they were going to do
I mean I'm gonna say like my money was
great Echo and the bunny man
um their album ocean rain which came out
in 84. I think is one of my favorite
albums of all time I [ __ ] love that
album I still listen to it all the time
like a lot of it like porcupine was
great like a lot of their [ __ ] was great
but ocean rain was like my favorite
every single song of that is good every
single song on that is good
um let's see Zach says it's also weird
how Leonard Cohen wasn't really that
good of a singer but he's also amazing
at the same time honestly that's kind of
like that kind of describes most
everybody that I like
because I think it's more important to
be
a distinctive singer than a good singer
technically
because the world is full of technically
good singers and technically good
musicians you know what I mean yeah
that's awesome but it's not that
interesting you know what I'm saying
it's like I know that stuff well it's
just kind of like you know as kind of
like a sideline the world is full of
like a beautiful people but a lot of
people that are beautiful kind of like
look the same as one another so I'm kind
of more interested in like someone who
stands out like who is distinctive in
some way and that kind of like goes with
looks that goes with talent that goes
with anything so I think that's one of
the reasons I got really into like Punk
and Post Punk and stuff like that is
because yeah a lot of those people
weren't great singers from a technical
standpoint but as soon as they sung a
note you knew who the [ __ ] that was they
were very very nice Robert Smith right
it's like as soon as they sang you know
who that is like that is a very
distinctive voice and I think that's a
lot rarer like I said it's very easy you
know I'm not saying it's easy like to be
a technically great singer but there's a
lot of those there's a lot of those
it's a lot harder to come out and like
be in a way and have a talent that comes
out in a way that it's like maybe not
technically correct or technically good
but is still like distinctive and really
like resonates well he's always been
folk and folk music sure that goes back
to Mississippi delta blues and stuff
they were like you know technically
those guys weren't any good
not by classical standards but they were
[ __ ] you know Howling Wolf and Muddy
Waters that's what I was saying [ __ ]
sounded great exactly yeah yeah you know
I'm down you know like that yeah see
that's and yeah [ __ ] like that that's
great yet it doesn't have to be
technically correct no I think that was
the reason that a lot of people and
particularly like why Punk came along
and it was kind of like a reaction
against prog rock because they saw that
prog rock was like you know they were
very interesting but like much like jazz
they were very interested in being like
technically
proficient and so they were just saying
[ __ ] all that we just want to like bang
out some [ __ ] and like do our own stuff
and let our own personalities come out
and it was a lot better it was a lot
more passionate because I kind of feel
like I don't know to a certain degree if
you're like technically really good at
something a lot of times like you lose
passion in the process and so your [ __ ]
doesn't stand out as much not always I'm
not saying that that's always the case
but like I said I think that's kind of
why
um you know I originally got into Punk
and postpon because a lot of those kids
when they you know there were kids that
started when they started those bands
they couldn't really play all that well
they couldn't really sing
um you know but they had the balls and
they had the passion and they got up
there and they did the [ __ ] and some of
the [ __ ] was [ __ ] great it was great
like because they were just enthusiastic
and it's like you know what I mean and
it stood out so I don't know I think in
some ways like it's important
it depends on the context yeah like I
said not I can't just say that across
the board yeah look at this
Amy Lee is technically great I like her
I [ __ ] love her [ __ ] and it's Gothic
metal
it's kind of crisp and kind of
her her sound is very clean and very
tidy for Gothic metal
it's almost too classical but I still
[ __ ] love it I think it's great and
she's technically yeah I don't yeah
she's not
you're not talking about a folk singer
you're not talking about a punk rock
singer or a goth singer or anything
she's just like somebody that would be
singing opera or something kinda and
it's just power metal and I can
appreciate that too I appreciate that we
saw her live she's great yeah I bought
him tickets one year for his birthday
she's great live and it was a good band
um
then there are some people that are
great
and it's not
technically great from a classical
standpoint but then they just make a new
standard and that would that would be
Rob Halford from Judas Priest going back
to the 70s and 80s not all of the albums
were good
but when he was good when they had a
good album and good material [ __ ]
Halford [ __ ] delivered
you know and he was great live too uh
I think he sounded best in the early 80s
you know 80 between 80 and 82 84 84
that's a turbo tour he still sounded
good but then the music started going a
weird way
70s and 80s man [ __ ] Rob Halford
people call him God
his metal god that's he trademarked that
[ __ ] he was the god of metal he has an
amazing voice amazing [ __ ] voice and
it was not
technically correct a lot of stuff that
he did but it just sounded [ __ ] great
that's right he made a new standard and
to me I kind of feel like that's what
matters yeah and I don't really know I
mean this might be kind of like out of
left field oh wait Louie's asking Jenny
is The Killing Moon on Ocean rain yes it
is
um it only has eight songs on it but
they're all [ __ ] fantastic that is
such a good album it's just so good and
that is like I I feel like in my opinion
that's their gothis album like some
people might like they were God that's
what I'm saying I you know a lot pretty
much every goth I've ever met likes Echo
and the bunny yeah that's of that age
you know what I mean and like I said
they were one of the first bands them
the second only first Modern English
um you know and then like a little bit
later like Bauhaus aliens X being but
like I think Echo and the bunny moon was
honestly the one of the first things
that I bought
um you could play that you could play a
lot of those songs off that album she's
talking about any goth club they'll
dance to it oh yeah oh yeah big time
even the young even the youngsters know
that
well yeah like I said I kind of feel
like nowadays because of the internet
and because all songs ever are
immediately available to everyone at all
times so I kind of feel like a lot of
maybe not entirely but I feel like the
whole like oh that's old music or
whatever I see I feel like a lot of that
distinction has disappeared or at least
has dissipated there's a lot of the
newer stuff to some degree in corporate
and so because the record industry is
not what it was the newer stuff is so
corporate and artificial they're
listening younger people are listening
to the old stuff and then people are
saying man 80s was [ __ ] great 80s was
great so it was 70s if you knew what to
look at knew to look for
I liked 90s they had some good 90s [ __ ]
you know remember gorillas I like them
[ __ ] yeah that's uh that's Damon
Albarn right he was in he was uh blur I
actually prefer blur to gorillas but his
head was great oh man yeah there was a
rate uh they had a lot of good [ __ ] that
kind of came and silently kind of came
and went over time but they were they
were really good 90s bands that
they're very talented um
what was I gonna say about that go ahead
Zach says it's weird I'm not much of a
Nine Inch Nails fan
but I love
um Trent Reznor's film scores they're
kind of experimental and atonal and very
unique yeah yeah he's okay um I kind of
feel like I saw Trent rezner I saw Nine
Inch Nails in 1990 live
um they were opening for Peter Murphy in
St Petersburg if you like Nine Inch
Nails you'd probably love you'd probably
love uh Gary Newman
anything 90s Gary Newman late 80s Gary
Newman he was [ __ ] great and he had a
lot of that not a Nine Inch Nails kind
of borrowed from Gary Newman
who is it uh
Gary Newman
and the guys from Depeche Mode I think
worked a lot together didn't they do a
lot they did yeah and then I think Trent
rezner also
was doing stuff with uh with with Gary I
think I think yeah yeah all of them like
they did a lot of uh stuff together yeah
well because the guy um and I prefer
Gary Newman his lyrics are [ __ ]
fantastic just go go listen to dead
heaven
Gary Newman dead heaven and read them
[ __ ] lyrics man yeah [ __ ] was
dark okay I'm not like I'm not casting
aspersions on Trent rezner but I do kind
of I do prefer Gary Newman like you know
in that way but what I was gonna say was
that I saw Nine Inch Nails live in 1990
they open he opened for Peter Murphy and
um at that time it's funny because
Pretty Hate Machine had just come out
and so hardly anybody knew who this band
was in 1990 like and it was early that's
it was spring or summer and so I had
Pretty Hate Machine because I had a
friend that had bought it and he's like
oh this is pretty everybody and he
copied it for me yeah like so I had
heard it so I was like oh these are
pretty good
um but like nobody everybody just sit
there and look looked at them which is
hilarious they were just like um what's
Peter Murphy coming on it was like it
was so funny because like nowadays
because they're like massively famous
and everybody knows who they are but
when I saw them in 1990 everyone's just
like sitting there looking at them by
the time 92 rolled around I was in the
Army every white dude in the Army had
that [ __ ] pretty yeah everybody
everybody [ __ ] happened that's what I
mean this was like before they blew up I
only had the album because I had a
friend that was like real he worked in a
record store and he copied it for me and
I was like oh this is pretty good it
kind of sounds like skinny puppy and
then like a little bit and then I was
just kind of like okay well they're
opening for Peter Murphy and me and a
bunch of my friends went to St
Petersburg like on the west coast of
Florida Saw Peter Murphy and Nine Inch
Nails were opening and they were doing
their whole thing like if you've seen
the um had like a whole video like with
all the tape like and all that kind of
[ __ ] that's kind of like what the live
show was like and so they were doing
that and I'm like wow they're they're
really like um you know leaning into
this and but everyone was just like
sitting there like Stoney face like
looking at them which I thought was like
[ __ ] another one around that time
that everybody every Everybody in the
[ __ ] Army if you were white and
you weren't a [ __ ] redneck rednecks
didn't buy this [ __ ] well no but uh you
know if they were doing all the [ __ ]
Garth Brooks and [ __ ]
and with big old long belt buckles yeah
I remember that [ __ ] I remember Garth
Brooks yeah they were doing that
are we they were still breaking my age
another one that hit another one that
[ __ ] hit was the cult and I think it
was [ __ ] what was it electric uh no
not electric uh
Temple something other [ __ ] something
other Temple Sonics Sonic Temple they
everybody had that album they played
that [ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't have it oh man
[ __ ] I'm not a big girl I'm not a big
fan I liked the cult I
that was a goth band too well I liked it
went full [ __ ] like I said I at the
risk of sounding like a hipster I liked
them when they were death Rock when they
were Southern death cult yeah they were
good but then when they went cult and
they went a little more La glam metal I
was like yeah I'm out I still liked it
I'm out Sonic Temple was a [ __ ] great
album and then there was another one
that was uh after that it was it was
also really good
and then it came out of one that had it
down black [ __ ] forehorned goat on it
that one was good too
um
it's just that it wasn't quite as cool
as it was because it's now mainstream
but if you listen to it I went back and
listened to it recently I said no this
is good
an electric electric that first [ __ ]
heavy album they came out was really
good I saw them live opened up for uh
Billy Idol on the Whiplash tour with
that smile to her back in uh I don't
know 87 might have been 87 88 something
like that and uh Pine Knob theater in
Michigan
grandpar's nose me and Steve would go
see that show
and uh
man they were great live fantastic
I don't know for some reason they just
never it was kind of like
I really got into the Sisters of Mercy
but I never got into like the mission UK
like I like some of their songs but I
never
their first album was good they got too
frilly
too soft I yeah that's the thing I kind
of I was like are you guys you too now
or yeah like they kind of started
sounding like mainstream YouTube it's
like I didn't really like that like if I
went back and listened to it now it's
still kind of like that well is it yeah
okay it is um but it's it sounds like
Bono singing
it's uh I know well that maybe that's
what kind of turned me off was like
Wayne hussy a couple of their albums had
that white one I forgot what it was
called something rather it was white it
was their first album and then I had
God's own medicine which is a reference
to Morphine if you guys know this
God's own medicine and it was and it's
got a they're pouring out a ball of
morphine it's pretty weird
uh and that was also good it was kind of
like Sisters of Mercy with but with Bono
singing
but it has a very crisp and clean sound
highly engineered see and I'm not
usually a fan of that I like more kind
of like grungy crunchy dirty dirty sound
basement sounding Yeah well yeah not
always but I'm that's kind of more my
job that was the thing about them even
in those days I was like this doesn't
seem to have street cred it sounds too
pristine yeah I don't like that I don't
like that yeah the recording qualities
were real good
um yeah which always makes me suspect
yeah maybe
I like [ __ ] Gene Loves Jezebel better
well yeah it is like discover was one of
those first albums I bought like on
vinyl yeah now the first album I bought
on vinyl was actually the police
synchronicity in 1983. I was 11 years
old I had albums before that but they'd
always been like bought for me like at
my request but when I had birthday money
in 1983 I said I'm gonna go buy I bought
the police synchronicity I think the
second album I ever bought was Modern
English after the snow which was
actually a year or two old at that point
because I think that came out in 1982
and then I think the third one was maybe
psychedelic first talk talk talk I think
that was the the next one but I bought
that on cassette not vinyl yeah I had
immigrant
and I had discover and I had a couple of
other ones and I loved them
yeah and discover was really good idea I
like that one and we saw him live at a
local pub here and well one of them the
twins have broke up and I saw one of
twins I don't remember we already know
which twin that was because they both
looked I just went up their Twins and
he's by himself you know what I mean
like Incognito like nobody knows who he
is I just walked him just says I want to
thank you when I was a kid I bought
immigrant and discover and in fact I
grew up listening to your band of I I
really appreciate I love you guys and
he's like thank you very much and uh he
I think he was impressed because
I looked my head was shaved then and I
don't think he realized that I was a
fast well the weird thing is that when
he was he was like wow okay you you know
me I said yeah I know you and and you
know and [ __ ] he was up there he
would he did the Porter and he did the
cow he did all their own plasti and all
that [ __ ] and we were right in the front
we were like holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] we did
all these yeah but a lot of people left
and it's only like [ __ ] 30 or 40
people and he's doing us and he goes
they all left but we all grew up
together I said that yeah we grew up
together and [ __ ] yeah I do like
almost I knew all but like I think one
or two of the songs that he did he's
saying the cow
and he had kind of like a backup bad for
hired it was only part of the band
because they had some problem with the
tour but yeah yeah we saw them but it
was it well I think he was excited like
I said because it did seem like well
Will's Pub is kind of one of those
venues where even if a bandit because
bands are always playing there so I kind
of feel like a lot of people will just
go there to like hang out and drink and
they don't give a [ __ ] like what band is
on so they're just like oh whatever this
is fine so I think when like a band
plays and like people get there and they
were they're really into it I think the
band is like really appreciative because
like oh my God we thought nobody knew
who we were yeah we're all singing their
songs kind of thing he looks down I
couldn't believe it I thought he was
gonna do like new [ __ ] like he did do a
couple new songs but it's like pretty
much every song that he did I'm like oh
my God this I know this song too I was
like off immigrant or discover yeah he
did like a lot of [ __ ]
which is a [ __ ] crazy you guys
probably have no idea what you were
talking about but you can go out and
just Google Gene Loves Jezebel
and go go immigrant look at that album
and then the other album was discovered
those two albums right there
[ __ ] classic Underground
kind of goth rock yeah or gothic Jason
off to Jason Rock Gus liked it yeah and
uh from the 80s I mean and they were
really good lyrics good you could uh and
they're they're from Wales yeah it's a
WellSpan and it was two twins
that were in the band and uh Paxton
twins yeah the Aston twins it never
works out though because look at [ __ ]
they started fighting look at [ __ ]
Jesus and Mary Chain now they weren't
twins but they were brothers right and I
think the same thing happened with Oasis
man like a long time like you have a
band with your brother and then like
after a while you didn't want to see
each other yeah and they're on the cover
and they
they were kind of like
wearing weird like Holly Hobby gender
bending looking kind of outfits with big
extensions and cool hair and [ __ ] it
kind of was trying to look a little bit
like strawberry or like a strawberry
switchblade I think a little bit
and uh the crowd from uh Neo folk crowd
from England they're kind of trying to
look up I'm just Oh I thought that was
uh I thought that was Pookie they try to
jump up on a chair kind of like uh
you know but when you see him you'll see
what I'm talking about but the music's
really good
real good
and it's just kind of traditional
Rock layout couple guitarists bass
player drum drummer
and uh vocalists and uh you can actually
see the original lineup doing live I
watched a live show on YouTube
uh I think it was off of [ __ ] the
Discover
album and it was great they were great
live
when they were together just they
started to fight over who should be in
the band so then it became in two bands
called YouTube
Jay astins G Loves Jezebel yeah and
whatever the other brothers yeah that
astons which seems a little petty yeah
but I mean well the thing about it is
that that's your bread and butter like
that band name so it's like I can see
how it's like yeah you can't really
leave it to like oh I'll just start
another band with another name but like
nobody knows who the [ __ ] you are so you
gotta start over from square one so I
get how like annoying it kind of
happened with Christian death
right that's what I'm saying that's what
Williams had a right to it and so did
[ __ ] Valor so there were two
Christian deaths for a walk in Valor
Valor yeah Valor did have some good
material but he did yeah yeah he did
have some good material I I liked it uh
Jatan Damone was usually working with
him
and she's the [ __ ] she's [ __ ] great
yeah I like her kind of a Blues singer
blonde chick
she was old back then and she but she
was hot she was like
40 something and just she has an amazing
voice holy [ __ ] white hair and bondage
outfits and you know incendiary love her
okay and it just sounded like she was
just like a blues man that's the way
it's off blues singer
but she did uh she did a great cover for
Christian death for uh
1983 a merman I should turn to be which
is a Jimi Hendrix Jimi Hendrix song yeah
yeah you could probably you can get it
on YouTube
and she [ __ ] does a great Jimi
Hendrix cover
um
but really
Roz Williams
is uh
his version of it was better he was kind
of like the gothic David Bowie he
sounded a lot like David Bowie and they
did they did some David Bowie covers
yeah he covered time that was probably
like the best thing
yeah all the guys love David Bowie man
that's what I mean see that's another
thing like David Bowie nobody would call
him a goth but all gods likes David
Bowie I can't think of I can't think of
a single person that's like into goth
music that didn't like David Bowie yeah
if you want to hear that album that
would be uh Christian death Iron Mask
try that one that one's got that one's
got um
uh [ __ ] what's his name in it [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] I'm getting drunk though yeah
you are uh yeah Roz Williams I think I
think Iron Mask is probably his best one
when you say
um I don't know like I'd have to go back
and when I hear the rat of time tattoos
of Bones kick over buckets I don't know
what was the one before that what was
the one before that
um
only theater of pain he's on that and I
think that was my favorite that's a good
one
I remember me and my brother used to
listen yeah I'm like that's the round
one yeah yeah yeah
I have it somewhere like I have like
piles of CDs around here someplace but I
don't ever listen to them anymore
because now you can find everything
online so whatever I want to hear
something Zach says I want to recommend
my favorite band you guys Poets of the
Fall I've heard of them but I don't
actually ever think I've heard they're
amazing uh Finnish rock group amazing
lyrics the singer has such an amazing
voice I think you'd like them very
diverse sounds
John Smith says uh okay I'll look them
up I have heard of that band but I don't
think I've ever ever heard of their
stuff not that I remember anyway John
Smith said first CD I ever bought with
my own money Alanis Morissette's Jagged
Little Pill yep
the first I remember that album being
pretty good though it was all right
um it's like on the charts I think it
was yeah that yeah it was everywhere
yeah I remember that but the first I
remember okay so the first vinyl album I
bought was synchronicity the police that
was 83. yeah it was good the first one
cassette that I bought was the walk by
The Cure I remember that the first CD
that I bought was extra Kate by the Fall
that was 1989 that came out
and yeah and I didn't actually have a CD
player when I bought it but I wanted it
so bad that I just bought it and I said
well I'll just take it to somebody
else's house my friend's house that has
a CD player and I'll tape it and then
like later on I got a CD player I didn't
have a CD player then but I bought it
because I found it in a store and I
wanted it
Joe Nash said do you remember when Lori
Anderson came out with oh Superman in
1982 yeah I remember that song I
remember that song and actually matter
of fact I was watching the uh mystery
science theater Turkey Day Marathon
yesterday which was streaming on YouTube
and they did the episode Warrior the
lost world and they make a Lori Anderson
joke in there which always makes me
laugh every single there's a bunch of
80s stuff that was Top 40 when I was a
kid it just bird it would just burn they
would just burn it into you and you
would just like get sick of it now you
hear it again I heard it again recently
and I was like man I forgot how good
Hall and Oates actually was yeah we were
talking about that the other day right
Hall and Oates was [ __ ] awesome yeah
right a [ __ ] man-eater I liked
man-eater at the time yeah their other
stuff not so much but I liked everything
I liked it I like it better now in retro
yeah looking back on it it was a lot
better very tight
uh and uh it had a it had a
flavor to it that was just really good
this Gestalt was good and I didn't
remember it being that good I heard I
feel like the the 1980s particularly
like their first half of the 1980s maybe
even in like the late 1980s I kind of
feel like there was this whole like
um white boy r b thing like which was
very much engendered by Hall and Oates
but then like later on you had a soul as
well that's yes so then like you have
like ABC like would do that kind of [ __ ]
like later on you like the Blow Monkeys
you had like bands like that that were
like white as [ __ ] but we're doing this
kind of like retro like r b thing which
I don't know it's like I I don't know if
I was like so into it at the time but
like when I hear it now like sometimes
I'm like oh you know what that was
pretty good you know what I mean every
now and then how
are we um it's only seven okay so we're
fine yeah it gets dark early now so yeah
you're fine you're fine
John Smith said creepy fact British
serial killer Dennis Nielsen listened to
oh Superman many times when killing his
victims wow that's great well
now accounting for taste I guess it's
like you know what I mean
I'm always like surprised when like
serial killers like cool [ __ ] though
you'd always think there are serial
killers they'd probably like some lame
[ __ ] but
every now and then you kind of I don't
know why but like I don't know why this
made me think of this but you know
everybody's seen Silence of the Lambs
right at the movie
so
Buffalo Bill like in the last scene
where uh where Starling is like going
down there like trying to get the girl
out of the you know basement or whatever
that song that's playing is
the fall and it's a song called hip
priest which is a great [ __ ] song I
love the Fall by the way
um and Kate and I know a lot of
Americans don't
I don't know it's a lot of Americans
don't really aren't really into them but
I I don't know like I I really really
like them I have almost all their albums
which is crazy to say because they have
like a million they put out like two or
three a year for a very long time uh not
anymore obvious sadly because Mark E
Smith has died but um yeah so I was
really into them so like when I first
saw that movie and I heard the song in
the background like are you [ __ ]
telling me that Jonathan Demi who
directed that movie is telling me that
like oh um people that listen to The
Fall are serial killers because I think
maybe I'm offended I wasn't offended but
I just thought that was funny that he
put that song in there you know what I
mean because I recognized it immediately
like while she was walking around the
thing like oh my God I recognize that
[ __ ] song you can you can barely hear
it like but I recognize it because I
really really like that song
Joe Nash said uh remember Frankie
Teardrop by Suicide yep I remember that
uh song John Smith said silence the
Lambs did ruin Goodbye Horses I don't
think it ruined it honestly it made that
song super popular you know what like
not last time we were at mannequins they
play Goodbye Horses every [ __ ]
gets out on that dance floor everybody
everybody
so everybody's still into that song and
that's it's cut silence and lamps that's
it's because Silence of the Lambs well
it's just kind of like you know how just
recently
um Everybody suddenly got back into
running up that hill that Kate Bush song
that's exact that's down to stranger
things stranger things featured it on
that episode and then now suddenly
everybody knows that [ __ ] song so
it's just kind of like and look I've
always loved that song and so now I
almost feel kind of like conflicted
because now they play it at the club
because all the people are like oh my
God it's a song from stranger things and
I'm just like well [ __ ] I kind of want
to dance to this song because I've Loved
this song like forever but now everybody
knows what this song is and now they're
gonna think I only know it because of
stranger things but but I've known about
the song since the 80s so it's just kind
of like it's very and it's kind of the
same thing it's like Goodbye Horses
is kind of the same thing I kind of feel
like that's you know people knew that
song beforehand but then when it was in
Silence of the Lambs then everybody knew
it a lot of people know the covers of uh
of uh Goodbye Horses more than the
original oh cute Lazarus was just a cute
Lazarus just an unknown unknown goth
band
I mean she was just a taxi cab driver
yeah at the time
yeah
it's crazy to think about yeah and
didn't she like singer is that singer
that singers that's a black female
singing a lot of people didn't she just
like go into like hiding or they
couldn't find her like for a long time
after or some [ __ ] like that it was just
like some one-off yeah some people think
that's a dude that is not a dude it's a
black female
and a goth dude doing that music
together I think that was I think that
might have been her boyfriend
I don't know okay but it's just funny
how
that [ __ ]
that just really resonated I guess like
for that particular scene yeah although
like I said that fall song Hit priest
was in Silence of the Lambs too and no
one gives a [ __ ] about that except me
because it's a great song
it is that's that's what I mean and it's
like honestly it's such a good song that
I don't even care like they'll play the
club I'll dance dude yeah I'll dance to
it yeah same with the Kate Bush song I'm
like ah [ __ ] it I'm gonna dance to it
anyway I don't care if people just think
I know it because it's a stranger thing
no it's no I knew it beforehand uh let's
see um yeah they're talking about hey
Dave you gotta go uh you going out
tonight he said he was going to
mannequins yeah okay he said he was
going to mannequins Zach says I watched
Silence of the Lambs recently and never
realized how cool the cinematography is
all those close-ups are so unique
honestly I love that [ __ ] movie and
you know I was thinking about it the
other day I don't think we've ever
reviewed that movie if we do that we
gotta do them all because I I actually
like Hannibal Rising the best out of all
of them
I don't know I like silence the Lamb's
best album but uh Hannibal Rising is
better but whatever they're all good but
even the one with uh
uh
okay not mine hunter that was what's the
it was like the last one number three
or number two
was good remember the guy who was eating
the pictures of the dragons
yeah
uh well the book was called red dragon I
don't know yeah red dragon that was a
good one and then um that was all right
I liked him Zach says uh oh damn I just
Googled uh Q Lazarus she actually died
this past summer
oh she did 61 years old okay yeah
there's been a couple covers of it too
because like sometimes
um they still play the cover of it too
like at the club sometimes I think like
last time we were at Memento Mori they
played like 61. that's dying Young
John Smith said uh seeing a weird Chris
Isaac Cameo as a SWAT team member see I
wondered about that too like I was
watching and I was like holy [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] Chris Isaac look at that
[ __ ] I don't know why he was
great
he's got a light yeah I really like he's
got a lot of this actually yeah I have a
couple of his albums somewhere he's
chill chilled out guy you know chilled
out music but it's just funny how he
just like turns up in these movies yeah
I think well wasn't he in a couple David
Lynch movies too I want to say yeah I've
got a lot of friends yeah
people like his [ __ ] he's good chill out
music Zach's like I miss [ __ ] hope
Sandoval
yeah she sounded great she had another
band with the dude from the Jesus and
Mary Chain yeah like one of the brothers
from the Jesus Mary Chain yeah what the
[ __ ] they called
that was a long time ago now I feel like
I didn't love it I didn't love like
their collaborations like it was okay
but honestly that Mazzy Star album
um not the not the one that everybody
has yeah some of something another stars
to see you write some [ __ ] like that
she hangs brightly what's the name of
the that was the one that I had that had
um Hala on it which is a great [ __ ]
that Mazzy Star album was the uh 90s
goth hookup album that was the album
that your goth girlfriend put on while
when you were gonna throw down
actually put the incess on and the
candles and [ __ ] put them as you start
album and it would just be straight
[ __ ] that was that was that was like
the God [ __ ] album
it was pretty much yeah
I [ __ ] hope singing her [ __ ] voice
was [ __ ] great it was kind of
it kind of sounded like switchblade
Symphony a little bit but just well it's
very
um real soothing uh yeah it's like it's
very laconic yeah it's very kind of like
yeah goth girls would put
Mazzy Star on or the cockatoo cocktail
twins yeah I could see that that was the
sexual albums and it wasn't just one
there were several girls that they did
that that was the 90s well yeah I could
see that I could see that it was good
music the thing about well the at least
the early Mazzy Star stuff was because I
know they got real big later but
I kind of got into them with their with
their earlier album they have like a
very like midnight in the desert like
I'm driving my car yeah my my
convertible like in the desert like in
the middle of the night and like nobody
is around and I really like that
that Vibe yeah you know what I mean I
think Hope was from the desert she was
yeah yeah like Mexican-American yeah
yeah
um
I think from New Mexico or Arizona or
something but it had a really cool like
night time in the desert kind of vibe to
it yeah which I really liked she wasn't
goth but her music was uh she looked
more
kind of folk
little dresses little dresses and stuff
little baby doll dresses and her hair
and I feel like in the 90s there was
kind of like a whole it wasn't goth but
it was like goth adjacent kind of thing
where you had these sort of like
these very wispy like female vocals and
so like you had like Mazzy Star you like
the pale Saints you had lots of people
like that we called it goth
I mean it's not quite ambient because I
think that's its own thing but like
that's kind of like what trying to
remember that I think it's goth etheric
that's what we called it yeah like our
ethereal yeah Gothic theory is what we
used to classify that as
even though they didn't consider
themselves to be golfbands and like I'm
sure like regular people listen to them
as well yeah
yeah but they they like I said though
they had the cool hair
and they wore little baby doll dresses
like little Wednesday Adam type dresses
they might not all be black but they
they dressed like that you can see
pictures of them
and they would uh had cool videos of
like them in the desert in cars and just
kind of there was a romantic element to
their material
and it's it had a feeling of depth to it
uh uh of a deep meaning
it may have all just been
a sleight of hand tricks
but the music was so good you could put
what you wanted into it you could read
into it
and they were just good chill out music
get high to it or
have sex to it you know when you're
young in your 20s you can throw down you
know [ __ ] that's how it was that's
how it was we didn't have [ __ ] mobile
Internet and mobile devices and you
weren't being inundated with data and
information and
time moves a little more slowly back
then and everything was personal and you
wrote letters and love letters and [ __ ]
to each other and [ __ ] now it's all
texts and emails and [ __ ]
he actually emails getting [ __ ] that's
old people [ __ ] but yeah
Zach says I love that I love that Chris
Isaac song that was in Wild at Heart
yeah Wicked Game Wicked Game that's a
great [ __ ] time I have that album and
I have like one other one I've had this
but I can't remember what yeah that is
John Smith says in my day
he's got a great voice yeah
and you know the fact that he was and
honestly like I really like a lot of the
music that David Lynch chooses to be in
his movies because David Lynch really
likes that like I said that midnight in
the desert Vibe I like music this is not
the only thing that I like but I really
like music that has a specific I don't
even know if there's a word for it but
it has this specific
vibe to it where I'm in my car I'm
driving on this abandoned Road in the
middle of the night somewhere and like
it's all like lonely and spooky and
there's like nothing else around and
you're listening to this song and I made
a whole mix like that like one time a
long time ago songs that gave me that
Vibe and I wish I had a word for it but
I don't I'm like not really sure and
like it's hard to explain to somebody
else unless you just give them examples
of it but that song is one like that and
like I said a lot of songs that turn up
in David Lynch movies he seems to like
that kind of [ __ ] too so it's that kind
of like vibe to it John Smith says he
liked Hannibal risings too under and
underrated under appreciated
it's um that was kind of like the uh the
Batman Begins of [ __ ] of serial
killer movies
how of how Hannibal had became who he
was and it was a classy European flick
and it was a period movie it went so
crazy it was a classic [ __ ] European
thing it's all classy and [ __ ] and uh
and they did a great job making things
period because they were in the 40s or
they had the [ __ ] Soviet t-34 [ __ ]
tanks they even had a bicycle strapped
to the side of the turret accurate
accurate when the Soviets ran around in
their tanks they'd have a bicycle
strapped to the turret people didn't
realize that because when you park the
tank how are you gonna go down to the
[ __ ] how you gonna get a beer how you
gonna go to town to get something you
know I mean because they were they were
Allied tank so they were mostly in
Friendly territory they rode on a
bicycle
you couldn't take the tank and then uh
accurate MV Augusta classic 1960s MV
Augusta or late 50s Envy Augusta [ __ ]
motorcycles and [ __ ]
um just did a good job of recreating
those air that era the guns
Tokarev [ __ ] TT Tokarev pistols just
um
I thought it was a cool flick and it was
kind of like the Batman Begins of serial
killer boobies
the Hannibal's kind of a good guy in a
way
and he just becomes a Savage
tribal Warrior like the Samurai and it
says how he became that way he was
judge jury and executioner wherever he
went if you were [ __ ] rude he was
going to eat you and then he got down
well how'd this how did cannibalism come
into this it makes sense when you watch
that movie
they hate his sister so he's going to
eat them and he got into that habit and
then he realized he became what he hated
he became what he hated you know I hate
when I get into the habit of cannibalism
yeah he became a camel and he was
accountable now and he hated it [ __ ]
you know because I need to quit doing
this seriously and then what's that I
said it's like whoops I need to quit
doing this yeah yeah
you need to quit eating people it's a
bad habit there's more to it than that
but I want to spoil the movie see
Hannibal Rising great flick I got it on
Blu-ray
no Bailey said Tom have you ever seen
the guy called liver King
yeah I've Just Seen little mostly
comments about liver King and videos
made by people in the and the fitness
scene online them talking about liver
kids what does he want to know about
liver King I don't know just asking I've
seen him
liver King's not natural if that's what
you're thinking
no he's on gear
look man
what's the matter I'm just trying to set
up my mind oh you're getting all inside
100 of professional athletes okay
100 effect of professional athletes
professional models and also are on gear
including
Bowlers and people that bowl
uh
people in the Olympics they're all on
[ __ ]
what it is is that they go on certain
kinds of [ __ ] that they need
and then they come off of it in order to
do the drug tests and then once a drug
tests are over they go back on [ __ ]
none of those people are natural
if you see ABS on a girl she's not
natural
if you see a dude who's over the age of
35 and he looks good he's not natural
um
there's such a huge stigma
which I think it's left over from
another era there's such a huge stigma
about anabolics and hormone replacement
that do people would go out of their way
to lie about
it and this goes back to the 70s Arnold
and
[ __ ] Sylvester Stallone and all those
[ __ ] Classics and [ __ ] they were all
on gear
testosterone goes back to the 1930s they
were all on that [ __ ] you can see guys
in the 50s he says man how'd they get
that [ __ ] build testosterone and
Anthony
this is a test they just took a lot of
it
so none of these dudes are natural
not not beyond [ __ ] 30. and if you
see dudes that you know are natural
at 30 they've been working [ __ ] 10 15
years they're not that impressive you
look at them you're like yeah okay
anybody who's impressive is not natural
but but what is natural bodybuilding is
not natural with lifting weights isn't
natural dieting is it natural the modern
diet of today with all these luscious
proteins and all this [ __ ] that's not
natural that
ancient people didn't have
access to the modern diets they were
lucky to [ __ ] just live the amount
that they did you know so
so what is natural you know
nothing's natural brushing your teeth is
not natural taking showers isn't natural
you know
you're cheating all y'all are shaving
isn't natural shaving isn't natural you
might as well just grow hair right
Isabella nothing's been natural for
[ __ ] thousands of years the ancient
Egyptians and the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
Romans and [ __ ]
tweezed shaved they weren't natural
either and they worked out they did all
kinds of [ __ ] had weird diets and
they measured Eugene Sandow measured
those statues and people said they can't
get that big no the Romans were got
pretty [ __ ] big because they had
Sports Medicine
they didn't have testosterone and or
anabolic steroids but
they knew how to work out they worked
out
which isn't natural and they eat high
protein but it seems to be based on
those statues okay I'm done Zach says uh
Clocks by Coldplay gives me that Vibe
but as the sun is rising yeah I can see
that that's kind of like I was trying to
remember like what all songs that I had
put on that mix I remember
speaking of echo in the bunny man I
remember the title song Ocean rain being
on there I remember tones on tail being
on there
I don't think it was burning Skies I
think it was that one that's like really
really long and slow yeah John Smith
said the Hannibal was killing Nazis in
the movie makes it but they weren't
Nazis
they were working for the Nazis remember
well same diff not really because then
they turned on the Nazis they were um
just a bunch of mercenaries
um I think
uh I think they were
they ukrainians I don't remember what
they were they were just something they
were just helping the Germans
but then they turned on the Germans and
just started stealing money and they
tried to escape in a uh and uh what do
you call it in an ambulance they didn't
care about any of that [ __ ] they were
just thieves thieves and cannibals well
they became cannibals because it got
snowed in it's a good movie though
Isabella said uh I like the ravenets
they have the type of sound you're
talking about yeah I like the ravenets
too actually they did a really good this
is probably like years ago but I
remember these were really good cover of
you know that stone roses song I want to
be adored yeah they did her they did a
really good cover of that I have a
couple of their albums somewhere like I
said I have like [ __ ] piles of CDs
around here but I don't know what
happened to all of them
uh John Smith said they were Lithuanian
lithuanians yeah okay yeah there you go
yeah there you go but yeah it's like I
don't know that's bugging me because I
feel like I made a whole like mix of the
of songs like that that I'm talking
about no I can't remember what was on
there I remember
I don't know I remember like two songs
that were on there but that was about it
that was a long time ago but I was gonna
say when they we were talking about
music earlier that about voices that are
I don't know maybe technically
not great but I don't know I don't know
if you'd say that though because I
really like I don't know if you guys
know but I really like um Rufus Wayne
Right and
I guess he's technically like a really
good singer even though
I don't know I mean Zach probably knows
who he is because it's like he's done a
lot of um he's done a lot of Leonard
Cohen covers he was on that because Zach
if you like Leonard Cohen have you seen
the documentary
I think it's called I'm your man and
it's like a live show with like all
these different and um Rufus wainwriters
on there Nick Cave is on there like
there's a bunch of other stuff like
interpreting
um you know Leonard Cohen songs and
honestly like roof Rufus Wainwright
doing the [ __ ] uh everybody knows is
[ __ ] fantastic that is like one of
the best [ __ ] covers that has ever
been done ever in the history of music
and I will die on that Hill
uh Zach says I'm also a big fan of John
Berry uh his orchestration style is so
elegant I really love his music for body
heat yeah I don't you know I'd have to
like listen to I'm not really familiar I
know that name though body heat that's
another movie we should probably do one
of these days
there's a lot of movies we need to do
still
you all right yeah
you sure I'm getting [ __ ] up I'm gonna
have to [ __ ] slow down on this well
yeah like I said well the thing about it
like we don't really technically we
don't have to leave for another two
hours
because they don't open until 10 and
it's only 7 30. yeah
so what would you have to leave it uh
around 9 30 around 9 30 because it takes
about half an hour to get there
so we still have like two hours before
we have to leave and like I said I'm not
an hour to get ready bro yeah I'm not
redoing the makeup I mean I'll I was
going to but I was like Jesus Christ I
don't have time to do that I was hoping
I'd have time to do it before the show
started but I didn't have time so I was
like well now I'll just like
we can do the show for about another 45
minutes probably something like that
yeah like half hour 45 minutes we're
fine and then it's like I already know
what I'm gonna wear I already pulled it
out so um what you gonna wear
well oh yeah she's gonna surprise me
well no it's not bad it's just like I'll
sit here and explain all the thing and
you don't know what I'm talking about so
it's like not really it's not really
gonna be boobalicious
I don't know maybe maybe okay I'm just
I'm just wearing [ __ ] I don't know I'm
not worried about it
um I'm not gonna wear a wig though
because no
well no because it's like it's already
I've been wearing this most of the day
because I recorded a bunch of videos and
it's like it's hot okay and it's like so
I'm just gonna like use my regular hair
okay
I might put my horns on though all right
I might do my horns
but I was gonna do it before the show
but like I said I didn't have time so
yeah I gotta I gotta make my bangs lay
down because I
pushed all my bags it's complicated all
the [ __ ] you have to do man
it's such a high maintenance it's a high
maintenance lifestyle well what cutting
it's not gonna make any difference what
I'm telling you is that to put a wig on
I have to make my bangs lay down in the
back now if I want bangs again when I go
out then I'm gonna have to get them wet
and like comb them forward and then
drive because otherwise they're gonna
like be plastered to the back of my head
you said I was talking about shaving the
undercuts remember if you I don't have
time to do that because because if we
did that then I'd have to wash it I
didn't say today okay I can do I can do
that for if you want well you just got
the idea to do that and it's like
I was like man no that didn't see that's
kind of what I mean the thing is though
is that when I'm talking about growing
the hair out I didn't necessarily mean
that didn't have the undercut and I mean
you could have both you can have long
hair like you have well I know yeah
right yeah that'd be cool because you
were complaining how hot it was
and I can I can give that back to you
that doesn't take long that's well I can
do it too it's like I did it myself for
a long time well touch it up but don't
you want to don't you want the uh The
Sideburns no longer you don't want
sibers absolutely not okay those are way
too they're they're they're they're
they're they're they're they're way too
high maintenance because yeah you gotta
get those things just right but when
they get along they looked really good
yeah but like the thing about it is that
if you don't get them exactly right like
if you cut them short like then it's
like a week later they look all [ __ ]
messy and [ __ ] like that it's like
what you do is it's like like a real
traditional old school
goth
female haircut is long hair
but it has an undercut it's really just
a top all right there's no hair anywhere
else which that's common now
but
parallel to the ear there's hair there
and it's like a Sideburn but it's long
it's about a foot long
that way you have
strips and it's it looks really cool
that looks cool
and uh I used to
cut that hair into her all the time and
do all the touch-ups and like it is high
maintenance to keep those yeah to keep
them because other because they get fat
and they start getting messy they say
get messy
yeah you know and you usually have to if
you're going out you usually have to
like moose them yeah or spray them so
like they don't like [ __ ] get all fly
away and Slappy looking right
they're an optional goth thing goth is a
high maintenance lifestyle yeah I saw an
old video of us at the club and she
that's back when she had she had that
with the sideburns and the under well I
call them sidebirds but they're kind of
like a Sideburn yeah sort of and and uh
the undercut and her hair was um
red
it was that [ __ ] bright red I had it
died right yeah it looked really cool
like Ronald McDonald ran well yeah I
liked it again everything in the house
gets red all the yeah all the sheets
everything he says yeah the inside of
the shower everything was red everything
was red and well because I had a diet
every week right
Black's better
well Black's better just because it's
easier it's it's better on your hair it
doesn't like because to do the red I
have to bleach it yeah it's real rough
on here and it's real rough on here like
the black is like usually and the black
if you like it if you decide you want a
different color you can just put a wig
on you know what I mean it's like it
seems a lot easier I did love the red
though I did love the red but it was I
didn't love how much work it took to
maintain that color because Clippers all
the time [ __ ] and this and then you
had to get that [ __ ] right well not just
that it was just like that [ __ ] kind of
want to curl and do this
I yeah it's wispy I mean well I don't
know what the deal is it's not straight
you got to pull them straight down you
got to cut them at an angle
to get them to come to a point and I
remember I mean I didn't mind doing it I
like that kind of fussy [ __ ] but you
know I think she got sick of asking me
to do it
yeah because like I said I'm a pretty
I'm a pretty chill like low maintenance
person it's like if anything's gonna
take that much time and effort I'm just
like I don't even know if it's worth it
you know what I mean yeah but like I did
like the red I like the way it looks
it's just that I don't like all the work
involved in keeping it looking like that
because like the hair looked cool bright
red but you know if you left it like a
week or two without putting dye in it
then it would start turning pink and
then like you'd have and it looked
shitty yeah you got to stay on top of it
you really have to like do it all the
time and I just got tired of like taking
care of it is what happened and my hair
is kind of a pain in the ass anyway
because I mean I have a wig on right now
but
my natural hair is kind of a pain in the
ass anyway because it's very very fine
it's like baby hair my sister's hair is
like this too because she said her
hairdresser complains about it all the
time and I'm like yeah I feel your pain
so it's like it's super fine like baby
hair but then there's like a [ __ ] ton of
it like it's really really thick but all
the hair is fine and every time I wash
it or brush it or run a hand through it
a bunch of it like falls out but it
never gets any thinner
today I was like going around today like
in my office and I was like scooting
around in my um like with my toes you
scoot around with your toes like on the
carpet of my office and it's like just
big hair balls will come out like just
of hair that's falling out like while I
was just walking around sometimes I got
a vacuum in here that's right well you
probably don't need to now because I
kind of like just clawed through the
carpet I was like oh my God gross this
place is always clean because she
doesn't really do anything in here you
know I mean well and I try to keep [ __ ]
clean in here you know what I mean it's
like I'm not a filthy person but I I try
to vacuum once a week up in here but
sometimes I forget it's just that it's
even if you did I mean even if it was
it's every week it's like you can't keep
up seriously every single day I have to
go in and like scoop like hair out of
the bottom of the tub and like it's all
over the bathroom floor and but my hair
never gets any thinner like I never look
like I'm balding or anything like I'm
like where the [ __ ] is no you just have
High hair I have a lot yeah I have my
hair it is it's crazy and like I said my
hair is just very very fine it's like
baby hair but there's like a [ __ ] ton of
it all right people go ahead and hit
that everywhere go ahead and hit that
like button people use [ __ ] many of
you in there that would help us out with
the algorithms
um
and um just remember the super chats are
[ __ ] wide open and if you all wanted
to buy us a drink you can go ahead and
[ __ ] uh drop us in this like we need
anymore
well once we get let me give a little
bit of this because man I got it I gotta
cut back I mean once we get some Memento
I probably will not they don't have any
real drinks anyway
I mean they just have like the one well
they have the ones in the cans those are
[ __ ] up I got on those things well
yeah but that's because you thought I
was slamming I thought you think I was
drinking anything that's what I mean
they were those Bacardi Mojitos in the
can in a can and I was just [ __ ]
slamming them like I said I'm never
slamming and slamming and slamming
everything you were even drunker than
you were on the show last Friday yeah
yeah I was [ __ ] loaded you were just
like [ __ ] I've never seen you that I
don't think I've ever seen you that
drunk before I hit a car on my way out
of the parking lot backed up boom right
into a car and I was like what the [ __ ]
is that I was like uh it's a car she had
to drive back I did yeah I was like get
out
yeah I had to take my boots off and
everything yeah because I can't drive in
those boots so I had to drive barefoot
that's okay I prefer driving Barefoot
anyway all right one of the things I'm
thinking about doing people is getting
into [ __ ] going back into into
leather craft I did yeah I was wondering
if you were going to bring them used to
go I used to be into leather craft but
not like Advanced leather craft
there's a lot of tools out there
to get and I was thinking about getting
back in the leather craft so I could
make cool [ __ ] I might sell some of it
might start up an Etsy store
or do something to to order
just you know anything bracelets
necklaces because you've made me some
belts in the past yeah I made belts and
[ __ ] in the past but I wanted to do some
more Gothic type stuff you know
um
could be anything
but I think it'll be pretty good pretty
good quality
I was thinking about actually even
making [ __ ] like boots boots and shoes
which is that's advanced stuff that's
hard but I got the skills to do that
kind of [ __ ]
just not the experience I I know I can
do it I just have to get the tools and
the time and I don't know we'll see if
my I like making [ __ ] for myself too you
know but I might get it might do
something like that leather corsets for
women
just uh
motorcycle armor Maybe
leather pants
[ __ ] like that
make some leather outfits
do some stuff that look like I got a
[ __ ] Edward Scissorhand looking
gothic stuff
see that'd be badass yeah
I told you you should probably get back
into that because like I said a long
time ago like you made me some belts and
like you know you kind of farted around
with that on a little thing but when you
told me the other day it's like oh I'm
thinking about getting back into that
and yeah it's like you were showing me
the videos and stuff like that and I was
like yeah that seems like something
another thing I want to make is do
pistol holsters custom pistol holsters
the other ones I saw some guys making
those of the guy yeah they're not as
good as some of the like the carbon
fiber tactical [ __ ] you have now but
there's there's some things that only
leather can do
when it comes to class
um and of course it would be custom to a
customer with uh designs and artwork on
it
you know whatever you know [ __ ] small
of the waste carry or under the shoulder
you know it could be anything
some of the [ __ ] I need measurements for
and uh
I don't know
I was thinking about it because I got to
make a bang costume yeah
I'm gonna do the bang costume with the
mask there's a kit you can do to get
like a film accurate version I'm gonna
get one of those
but I have
I have a [ __ ] um
basically a low low military load
bearing vest that is real close to
Bane's armor
I just got to build an armored front for
it
it doesn't really have to be and it's
all Molly it's all Molly attachments so
I could get that to work and add a belt
to it
and it's got it's got to be OD green and
I'm not going to make [ __ ] you know
ballistic armor it's just it doesn't I
don't need that that's not the
application
so it's not gonna be real armor it's
just and I'm just thinking that probably
foam and leather and stitching and
[ __ ] would be enough to make a front
to put on the thing that I have now
and uh that would pretty much be Baines
armor from the Batman movie
because
they sell a replica for about 70 bucks
but the quality doesn't look that good
and I think for [ __ ] half of that I
can take what I have and turn that into
a
into a bang costume
and um gonna get the pants and
everything and I'll practice that voice
the one I can do that because I can do
that I can do the Danny Trejo [ __ ]
voice when I'm warmed up I was doing
that [ __ ] to the kids out there [ __ ]
for [ __ ] Halloween
I was did the DC Comic version of Bane I
had the Bane Luchador mask on and I was
doing the den kind of like a Denny Trejo
version
of because he was Bane he did he voiced
out Bane in the cartoons one of the
cartoon movies
but I was having fun out there with the
kids but um I wore that to the club
[ __ ] people liked it at the club too
but I want the other big costume
the one from the movie
with the [ __ ] yeah evil mouth on it
and they make that thing but it's kind
of a cheap version and then there's a
french guy on Etsy that makes a kit
that's a lot more movie accurate
that you have to assemble and paint
you have to wait a long time for it it
costs a little bit more but it's just
like it's just like it was in the movie
I think I might get that one because I
have time
yeah I have time until next year
because if I'm gonna do Bane it's gonna
look [ __ ] badass it's gonna look well
see that's the thing if I'm gonna do
werewolf like because we were like we
were talking about right then I'm gonna
have to start like you have to start
doing it now planning like right right
now I have to start I have to start
planning to [ __ ] in January because
that's going to be
several hundred dollars worth of stuff
to get together and I don't want to lay
all that out once and be pressed for
time you know but that's probably a four
or five hundred dollar costume
um because I need those [ __ ] combat
pants that he has which I know where to
get that stuff
because I'm gonna do the bay mercenary
outfit
it's gonna look good
Glenn little said that's a great idea I
always believed uh creativity makes
people well-rounded I know I sound like
a pretentious prick but it's true no I
do that's the way it is yeah I feel like
people need skills or you need to like
create something make something even if
it's not it doesn't have to be like a
super big deal or anything like that but
I always feel like you need some kind of
like creative Outlet or yeah or that's
it's good for your like mental health
yeah skills and variety of skills gives
you a greater connection to the force
yeah it does yeah
um it allows you to channel the force
better
um Life Energy
yeah that's that's indeed Chi and
philosophy you know
uh the will and [ __ ] to harness the
will
but uh no I already have I already have
the uh artistic skills for it and a lot
of the dexterity and stuff I just need
the tools
um but no I because I've already made
stuff like that before yeah so um
there's nothing compared to mechanics
you know Building engines and [ __ ] a lot
mathematics involved and [ __ ] gauges
and
understanding of how systems work with
each other
artistic skills like making
ballistic armor and [ __ ] outfits and
stuff you know that's
not as precise but still
you have to have good execution or it
looks cheap yeah this shit's got to look
like it's the real thing
and I was looking at some of this other
stuff that guys have made handcrafted
like handcrafted leather viking armor
that's better than anything out of any
Factory
to what they were doing
a factory couldn't make that
they had a guy I was showing Jenny he
was making just wallets he was just
showing tools but the wallets he was
making all these multi-colored leather
looked better than any Coach bag or any
Gucci it was like at that level
well like I said if you just made each
Unique Piece like you could charge a lot
of you could charge a premium for that
because it's like that's the only one
that's like that yeah it wasn't designer
but he had it in his studio and you
looked at it just beautiful leather they
were really nice
his color combinations were just great
you know
it looked like
something you pay a thousand dollars for
well yeah [ __ ] I'm always like really
into people that do stuff like that like
they can like make stuff out of leather
or it whatever it is it's just kind of
like you know you can write songs you
can like decorate cakes you can do like
all that kind of stuff like it's
whatever it is it's like good to have
like creative skills like that it really
does kind of like keep you
sane in a lot of ways grampster said if
you rented a kiosk at the Orlando Mall
you could sell leather cell phone and
cigarette holsters with designs on them
old people love that [ __ ] and will pay
top dollar for custom-made products
they probably would I don't know like I
don't know about the mall I don't think
that would be the best thing no well I'm
almost here is [ __ ] dead well they're
except for Altima they're low income
that's actually like pretty crap yeah
yeah ultimates the thing is that they're
low income
the people that are in there
uh there's one mall here uh [ __ ] so
they're not gonna spend a lot of money
they don't have the money uh there was
one mall here though uh that Dan Bell
did that was in Miami it was in Miami
and you had to be rich to be in that
mall they had models walking around
[ __ ] showing these [ __ ] gowns you
could smoke in there
they were [ __ ] selling they had
Bugattis outside
[ __ ] koi ponds and [ __ ] he said even
the koi pond even the koi were snotty
that's like I love that's my favorite
dancer
the big old fish [ __ ] you
said that whole and it was uh it was
like an open-air mall it's crazy but
they made it in a way to where you could
have pouring down rain and it would
still be dry yeah you'd still like stay
dry yeah it was funny because there was
like a like a tropical depression yeah
and they're serving alcohol and smoking
out there and there's just very it was
very French yeah very French and
international a lot of middle easterners
middle easterners and South Americans
Super Rich South Americans
and uh
uh he was looking at a what was it it's
a jewelry store and that wouldn't that
watched like nine thousand dollars no I
think it was more than that more than
that twenty thousand I thought it was
more than that even more okay I don't
even remember but it was like more than
a sports car
yeah it was a forty thousand dollar
watch I think wasn't it yeah and they
just handed it to him he's like hey look
at it yeah Zach says I still think it'd
be funny if you guys dressed as normies
for Halloween one year I mean you look
like Halloween basically every other day
I don't well the thing about it is like
one I think yeah yeah you would just
look like everybody else and two I'm not
really sure I'd know how to look like a
normal person yeah
when I tried before like for job
interviews and stuff it didn't go so
well
I'm just I'm not really good at that
kind of thing Tammy said uh I could see
Tom in a polo shirt and khakis it here's
the thing if I dress like that
it doesn't look like a costume right it
doesn't look like me anymore and it's
just like it's not it's not as impactful
as you think right
um yeah it only works if like people
know you oh yeah
like the only like our friend Shawna
dress up as like a normal person when
you're but she won she did like a little
bit of a retro thing yeah she was like a
a a a hot black chick from the seven
from the 70s so it was a little bit of a
retro Vibe but I think it was funnier
because we knew her right and so that's
what was funny because when she came in
I was like holy [ __ ] like I didn't even
recognize her at first but it's like if
you didn't know her it probably wouldn't
be that funny but it was funny because
we know her and that's like that's not
what she lives although you know what
talking about this custom-made [ __ ] now
they're thinking about it me making that
Bane armor if I were to do some really
cool custom [ __ ] I would do something
like what you doing Pokey what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you doing what is she
doing I don't know she's like she
climbed up something but I can't see her
I can't see her either where are you at
Polk I would make some like custom AR
500 and carbon based [ __ ] ballistic
armor
that would be real
I I know everything about all that kind
of stuff
it would cost a lot of money though it'd
be something that would be Bulletproof
but who would want something like that
see that's the thing
it would have to there aren't any
superheroes out there that we know of
that we know of you know I mean but
[ __ ] I could make something like that
for myself
thank you Jeffy all right super broke
this week I hope you guys enjoyed t-day
we did thank you thank you yeah we ate a
lot well we didn't eat a lot but you
know a lot for us granther said 10 years
ago I paid a hundred dollars for a
leather wallet from the will leather
company out of Eugene Oregon Oregon
it still looks as good as new if you get
what you pay for yeah yeah so see that
was only ten dollars a year yeah so far
well they have a bunch of different
grades of leather and some stuff just
doesn't age some of it's shitty some of
it's [ __ ] great
and um okay well here's the thing I have
a pair of [ __ ] um Matterhorn boots
that the Army issued me special issue up
in Korea
and they're uh they're an Arctic
oh you were in there
she was in the couch I wondered where
because we kept hearing noises over
there I'm like I can't see her though I
know she's up to something she was in
the cabinet [ __ ] around they issued
those things to me in 1991
I walked all over Korea for them for a
year they were in [ __ ] hard service
and they're an extreme cold weather
leather boot
afterwards I gave it to my dad and he
wore them all the time [ __ ] deer
hunting he gave them back to me they
still look brand new those things are
[ __ ] 35 years old
still look pretty much brand new because
everything on it can be it was real
leather so everything could be re-dyed
repolished
um the the the soles were so high
quality they wore only a little bit
there's Footwear out there made in the
1920s that you could put on right now
and [ __ ] and go out and just walk
down and do military service in them
because
they were not really synthetic materials
they were you know what I mean they were
[ __ ] natural materials and they wear
real well and they used really good
stitching and [ __ ] they were
semi-handmade it lasts for a long
[ __ ] time
or it can be repaired if it doesn't
in a way I kind of feel like that's one
of the shitty things about you know
um me like personally like growing up
poor and stuff like that is that you
know
just you know from a general standpoint
that it's better to like buy something
that's expensive that'll last for a
really long time
but when you don't have a lot of money
it's like man I don't have the money to
drop 200 300 it's like on a really good
pair of shoes even if they will last you
know however many years you don't have
the money at that point so you keep
having to buy like these cheap ass like
10 20 pair of shoes and then like in a
year you have to buy another pair but
it's like you know generally like the
more you pay for so well not always
because sometimes you're just paying for
the name and stuff and this other room
over here I have a 1941.
naval officers long coat out of made out
of wolf it's black from World War II
it weighs about 10 pounds all right
1941 and it looks brand new
that thing's probably worth hundreds
hundreds of dollars
have that showed yet you showed you that
I don't remember ever seeing that now no
um how can that have been in this house
all this time that like I never saw it
I'll go get it oh you're gonna go get it
yeah
well hey Blaster one said Jenny always
looking cool well thank you very much
thank you very much
and let's see
last one said also is a getting better
fell off a roof holy [ __ ] broke my wrist
tore my rotator cuff and had 19 Staples
in my head God damn it
that's terrible I mean you know
at least you're kind of all right that
sucks
um Camp guy said my old man had some
black leather military gloves he got in
the army they are
shells I can't read that and the inside
part of the glove is wool fabric ladder
olive green he also uses army boots for
decades after he left the Army yeah
that's the thing like
you know if you spend a lot we were
talking about that before when we were
talking about like goth boots and we
were talking about like two hangers
because look how heavy it is oh okay oh
yeah yeah I remember you showing me that
I didn't realize I didn't realize it was
that old though yeah okay yeah I gotcha
too bad it never gets cold enough here
to work never gets cold enough to wear
it cold in Boston though
well yeah but like I said okay look it's
75 [ __ ] degrees outside right now and
it's almost eight o'clock I think it's
got the guy's name in it
does it really
where's the light
[ __ ] man
I don't know I can't see that let me go
get the it's too dark
I think it was 1941.
I can't see it
had to put it on two hangers
you gotta put that [ __ ] on and he's like
he's like already oh my God that's so
hot
see that's [ __ ] cool looking look at
that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's Gothic [ __ ] especially with his
boots and stuff yeah you should wear
that out you'd know it's too [ __ ] hot
I was gonna say you die
like I said it's eight o'clock at night
and it's 75 degrees still
it was hot today it was in the 80s
we had some nicer weather like last week
we had a couple days where it only got
up in the 50s or 60s in the day but yeah
that didn't last
today was I think 85 80 something like
that
something like that I wish it would cool
off but you know
yeah Hugo said awesome coat Nosferatu
style it is yeah that's what it looks
like it looks like the nasaratsu coat
we were he was uh
he has like a bunch of like um coats
that he used to wear out because he was
like reminiscing about
um a video like our friend Matt like
sent us this video that was of us but it
was like 10 years ago I think and I was
like man look how cool we looked back
then and like the jacket that he had on
he's like I don't even know if I can
wear that anymore because like you know
he's his arms and stuff are much bigger
now because of the workout and stuff but
he tried to like he tried it on last
night and actually it fits even better
than it did back then you know
Zach says goddamn water coat like that I
know that's awesome like I said it's way
too hot down here to wear that like wool
you would [ __ ] die you would Keel
over
of heat stroke within like an hour of
wearing that it looks awesome though if
we went somewhere cold he could wear it
Blaster ones that don't want to meet Tom
in a back alley with that on yeah that's
that's how that's gonna go
it does yeah I don't
I think that he showed me that coat
before or I remember seeing it in the
closet but I didn't realize that it was
that old I think is what it was and I
didn't realize that it was actually wool
I don't even it's it's kind of
depressing because I have I don't have
any wool coats obviously but
I have a bunch of really cool like goth
coats I have like a couple of velvet
ones but
it's this you can never wear them we can
never wear them it's just way too
[ __ ] hot down here
like even if it's kind of cold out like
you wear it for an hour or two and then
everybody's like yeah I gotta take this
off I gotta take this off
uh Zach says I have a show topic
suggestion by the way disastrous movie
productions was watching a show about
Heaven's Gate and how it basically
killed United United Artists in the 80s
that actually might be an interesting
show
like because there were some times where
like just one movie kind of like sunk a
whole [ __ ] Studio
so that might be something interesting
to do so I'll uh I'll take that under
advisement
Camp guy said uh my grandfather left me
a coat like that all pure Cashmere
I think it may have some moth damage
also I'm too big for it yeah I didn't
how hot was that [ __ ] coat when you
put it on uh well it takes a while it's
all it's it's wool that's what I'm
saying so you know I wore that [ __ ]
Sub-Zero out in Boston all the time and
took it in New York last time I went to
New York and had one of the construction
guy goes man that's a badass coat and it
says 1942 or 1941 he goes God you don't
mean nothing like that no more
because you look at it you go they don't
make things like that anymore Zach said
it looked like nosparatu kinda yeah yeah
it does kind of if uh if they make
something like that now that's a couple
thousand dollars worth of [ __ ] coat
that's what that would be yeah yeah
last one said you've done anything on
Dennis Nielsen yeah we did a show about
him it was a while back though I kind of
feel like we just show about him right
it was a couple years ago probably
says goddamn want a coat like that
Blazer says don't want to meet Tom in a
back alley with that Gat on put that on
with that on okay yeah
I figured it out
yeah Blaster went to the English version
of Dahmer yeah Dennis Nielsen was
essentially like and they caught him fun
you know fun fact because uh he was
flushing little bits of people down the
toilet and it like clogged up the toilet
and all the other people in the building
were complaining yeah remember that we
didn't yeah we did a show about that
[ __ ] didn't know how Plumbing worked
either that or he was just yeah it's
just like I'm just gonna flush it yeah
down the toilet it'll be gone I'm like
um that has to go somewhere yeah well
and also like I think when they came up
there he was still had some people in
like some dead people in his like
[ __ ] wardrobe yeah yeah rotting and
rotting yeah and then he have like some
[ __ ]
until like [ __ ] that's not funny but
it's like did he have some [ __ ] uh
what do they call it like [ __ ] scent
what is this thing called I don't know
[ __ ] air freshener air freshener
there you go that's what I was trying to
think of like the air fresheners in
there that was England you know when he
was in a city in in a built up area
those are not country people they don't
know how to deal with like you know
cleaning deer and dealing with [ __ ]
you know meat processing you know if you
make a Kill
on some venison you know so
I guess they let things rot they don't
know how to cut things into pieces or he
just liked having it in there I don't
think so because like I said Dahmer
likes to keep the bodies around maybe
the smell I I just can't understand it
you know it was rotting you know
look
I used to be able to take my dad bought
me a little skinning knife it was called
an old timer
and it was about a three and a half inch
blade that was taking plenty ideas
I'm just telling you the facts of life
it was a little three inch curved blade
that came to a point
and with that little skinning knife
you can render an entire
deer you know 70 80 pound deer
down into nice little fillets and pieces
and not get any blood anywhere in the
kitchen and yeah you had to work outside
a little bit you know your head to field
dress a deer to get the guts out of it
when you were out there
but that's nothing if if you had to do
that in a house it wouldn't be a d if if
you're an organized person who
understands thinks you could do that in
a house and not spill a drop of blood
not make anybody yeah but if you're an
organized person who did that if you
wouldn't be a serial killer would you I
guess not I guess so it's a moot point
they're trying to make it some kind of a
Macabre [ __ ] thing or they just don't
have the skills they let things rot and
no you could take a body just with a
little tiny sharp blade and render it
into nice little pieces and have it all
packaged up and it's it's not
morbid or anything and take it out
little by little
you know
and not make a mess they rarely do that
but for some reason they don't seem to
be able to do that well like I said
because they're serial killers if they
had their [ __ ] together they wouldn't be
serial killers right would they you're
right duh
that's why they're not thinking right
yeah so
it's it's kind of like giving them these
Pro tips it's really not helping because
it's like Stone Age man would take
little pieces of Flint that were like
the size of a [ __ ] silver dollar or
[ __ ] obsidian little [ __ ] glass
and four or five guys would take an
elephant and they'd or or a big old
Bison and just render it down to nothing
in a short period of time you know
without any running water or anything in
there
eating it and sharing it and
it's nothing really Macabre really you
know it's just
you get used to it
last or once that I found a samurai
sword in a roof space we renovated wow
it may have not have been it's old and
needs restoration but okay
well a lot of times find all kind of
cool [ __ ] A lot of times guys brought
those back from the Second World War I
don't know what country he's in but I
guess it must be United States
a lot of guys brought them back but
another thing is that they made a lot of
copies too so
a lot of times if you were they'd have a
handle on there and it was all wrapped
up a shark skin and depending on if it
was a good one or not and underneath
there there'll be a bunch of markings to
tell you who made it
but I wouldn't recommend messing with it
at all unless you give it to an expert
but they're an expert would probably
know exactly what it is and what it was
worth before they even took it apart
if you just take pictures of it and
[ __ ] post it in certain places
they'll probably guys will probably tell
you what it is
yeah right yeah okay would you expect me
to say something else well I'm never
sure
do you have any stuff in general from
second world war is not really worth all
that much it used to not be worth
anything I think it's gone up a little
bit but the pistols aren't worth much
the rifles really arisaka rifles aren't
worth much
there's very few of them that are worth
anything
World War II Japanese swords aren't
worth all that much for last I heard old
stuff is but not the World War II stuff
yeah I get it all right so it's getting
to be past eight and I probably have
yeah we should start getting ready okay
because we're gonna go out
to Memento Mori this evening and we have
to leave in about an hour and a half so
I like need some time to get ready
probably should we have like a sandwich
or something yeah you want some I'll
make you some all right I wouldn't mind
like just sandwich them all right so
we're gonna wrap it up so we'll be back
on Sunday and we'll be talking about a
movie we don't know which one yet
because we haven't watched it I don't
know if we're gonna maybe we'll continue
like the universal stuff because I just
put up the Creature from the Black
Lagoon uh review earlier today so we've
been having fun doing those so I don't
know maybe we'll do another one of those
or maybe we'll do some Hammer I'm not
really sure like whatever we figure out
we'll talk about that on Sunday so you
guys have a good rest of your evening
and have a good day tomorrow and we'll
be back again on Sunday and we'll see
you guys then so good night